I'm Jim Hansen I'm a climatologist I
work at NASA and also at Columbia
University
yeah well human-made global warming is
caused by changes in the atmosphere
which are due to burning fossil fuels
primarily as we burn oil gas and coal
this releases carbon dioxide to the
atmosphere and carbon dioxide absorbs
heat radiation from the earth and that
traps the heat radiation and makes the
planet a bit warmer so we notice that
the world has warmed up about one and a
half degrees Fahrenheit in the last
century with most of that warming in the
last 30 years
there's now 387 parts per million of co2
in the atmosphere 150 years ago it was
280 so it's increased by a hundred and
seven ppm what we thought a few years
ago was that it would probably be safe
to let co2 go as high as 450 parts per
million the reason we thought that was
that we know that there were previous
periods in the Earth's history called
interglacial periods we're now in a warm
interglacial period which we have been
in for about 12,000 years but there were
prior periods when the earth was warmer
than it is now and the planet was still
pretty much the way it is now
and we thought that it was then about a
degree or so Celsius which is about two
degrees fahrenheit warmer than it is now
and we thought that might be okay to be
that warm and 450 parts per million
would probably take us to that sort of a
climate but what we now realize is that
during those prior warm periods sea
level was about six or seven meters
higher than it is now and also we see
what's happening with the current 387
parts per million that's already enough
that the Arctic sea ice is melting
mountain glaciers all around the world
are melting which is going to affect the
freshwater supply for billions of people
the climate zones are shifting so the
Southwest United States and
Mediterranean region are becoming hotter
and drier
likewise Australia so you see increased
forest fires and reduced water supplies
in those regions coral reefs are already
under stress they're going to many of
them are going to be lost if we continue
with increasing greenhouse gases so we
realize already the 387 is actually too
large about 350 parts per million is a
more realistic target and that means
we're going to have to phase out you
of coal over the next couple of decades
if we want to be able to get back to 350
parts per million
look at the fossil fuels we see how much
carbon there is in oil gas and coal and
by far the largest is coal and we know
that we're going to use the oil in the
gas it's very they're very convenient
fuels the big pools are owned by Russia
and Saudi Arabia they're certainly going
to sell that gas in oil if we want to be
able to get back to 350 parts per
million it's this huge coal reserves
that we're going to have to leave in the
ground or we could burn the coal and
capture the co2 and put it back in the
ground but that's very difficult we're
gonna have to move beyond fossil fuels
sometime within the next century anyway
so why not do it now and preserve a
climate that will allow our children and
grandchildren to have the same sort of
planet that we enjoy and with all of the
species that are still on the planet
huge step and that is putting a price on
carbon emissions it's it's really that
simple if we put a gradually increasing
price on carbon emissions by putting a
tax at the source at the mine or at the
port of entry where the fossil fuel is
imported to our country then as that
price rises then energy efficiency
renewable energies nuclear power the
other forms of carbon free energy can
compete more effectively against the
fossil fuels but in order for the public
to accept this and in order for the
public to have the money to invest in a
new vehicle and insulating their home we
have to give all of this money to the
public if we put a price on carbon
equivalent to one dollar a gas a gallon
of gasoline that would generate 670
billion dollars in one year in the
United States if you return this to the
public to legal residents of the United
States that would be $3,000 per adult
legal resident and if you give half a
share to children up to two per family
that's $9,000 per family with two or
more children so that would give the
public the money to make the changes in
their lifestyle that are needed to move
us off of fossil fuels into a cleaner
future because right now the fossil
fuels are the main source of air
pollution pollution which is killing in
the United States about forty to fifty
thousand people per year worldwide a
much larger number than that because the
pollution is much worse in China and
India than it is in the United States so
we have many reasons to want to move
beyond the fossil fuel era
it could happen very easily if our
governments would move in that direction
and by the way if this has happened it
is happening now in British Columbia
Canada they have imposed a carbon tax
with the money returned to the public
they do it via a decrease in payroll
taxes I would rather see a dividend
because half the people are not on a
payroll either they're retired or
they're out of work but you could use
say half of it for a payroll tax
deduction and half of it for a dividend
a nuclear power the kind of nuclear
power that we have now is called
second-generation
nuclear power it's it's a comparable in
cost to coal once you have the nuclear
power plant then the fuel is very
inexpensive so nuclear power is quite
inexpensive but it's difficult in the
United States to get a nuclear power
plant built then it takes so many years
that it drives the cost up so now in
England they've realised that they will
need to have nuclear power in the future
so they've put a limit once a government
Commission decides on where the power
plants will be built the public will
have one year to object to this and
possibly get some changes but they can't
drag it out six or seven years the way
it happens in the United States because
that drives up the price tremendously
and there's also the possibility for
fourth generation nuclear power that's a
technology which allows you to burn all
of the nuclear fuel presently nuclear
power plants burn less than 1% of the
energy in the nuclear fuel 4th
generation nuclear power allows the
neutrons to move faster so it can burn
all of the fuel and furthermore it can
burn nuclear waste so it can solve the
nuclear waste problem and the United
States is still the technology leader in
fourth generation nuclear power in 1994
Argonne National Laboratory now called
Idaho National Laboratory was ready to
build a fourth generation nuclear power
plant but the clinton-gore
administration cancelled that research
because of the anti-nuclear sentiments
in the Democratic Party well we are
still have the best expertise in that
technology and we should develop it
because it's something that we could
also sell to China and India because
they're going to need nuclear power they
don't are not going to be
to get all of their energy from the Sun
and from the wind
active ones energy efficiency we waste a
lot of our energy we can get vehicles
that get more miles per gallon there
there are many ways to improve energy
efficiency in fact some states are twice
as efficient as other states just
because it fossil fuels were so cheap we
just didn't pay attention to how
effectively we were using them but in
addition their renewable energy solar
energy wind energy and I think that
nuclear power has to be part of the
solution because at this time it's the
only alternative to coal for baseload
electrical power and we do now have the
technology for much safer and more
efficient nuclear power as compared to
the old versions that were used in the
past several decades
you know Obama is still perhaps our best
hope but he's going to have to study
this problem and understand it presently
his approach is to let Congress debate
it and make their there a horse-trading
and end up with some sort of compromises
with the polluters and then we end up
with this cap-and-trade and offsets and
a completely ineffective system but this
isn't now this situation in which we can
see what we are doing to future climate
and what the implications will be for
young people we're we're in danger of
said sending them into a situation where
dynamical system will be out of their
control
but this the intergenerational injustice
of that is and this problem is analogous
to that faced by Abraham Lincoln with
slavery or Winston Churchill with Nazism
it's not a problem where you can
compromise Lincoln couldn't say well
let's reduce the slaves by 50% yeah you
can't compromise on this we have to
phase out the carbon dioxide emissions
over the next several decades and and
frankly that means phasing out coal
emissions and this cap-and-trade system
doesn't do it at all
are they're taking the easy way out the
they're allowing the polluters to write
the bill the the waxman-markey bill in
the house is 2,000 pages long do you
think that representative Waxman wrote
this no this is written by the polluters
and even by environmentalist there are
good points in those bills also it's
filled with the polluters point of view
and and some environmental things to
increase solar power for example but
that's not going to solve the problem
it's just like the old Kyoto Protocol
approach we they have to face the
fundamental issue as long as fossil
fuels are the cheapest energy then they
are going to be burned and their use
will continue to increase you have to
face it that's what the lawmakers are
not facing and that's what President
Obama has got to understand so the only
way you can address that is by putting a
rising price on the carbon emissions
then the alternatives the renewable
energies energy efficiency nuclear power
anything that doesn't produce carbon
will compete more effectively and those
which are most effective will begin to
win economically
yes there are people in Washington who
get it there
there is one bill that was introduced in
the house which had a gradually
increasing carbon price the democratic
party it was introduced by a Democrat
and I'm sorry I can't think of his name
at the moment but it was conveniently
ignored by the Democratic Party we've
got to have a an open discussion of this
I think you know the public is not
excited about this issue the way they
were about health care but we need to
have that kind of an an open discussion
so that we see what the alternatives are
because this approach that is being
pushed by the Democratic Party is a
disaster
activism is going to be necessary it
seems so we have to draw attention to
the intergenerational injustice in
climate change you know I went to
Massachusetts because I recognized that
they're very progressive state and I had
hoped that you know we have to find one
state that will take an approach that
works and that means a carbon price with
the money a hundred percent of the money
returned to the public there's a
province in Canada that's doing that but
people in the United States don't pay
that much attention to what's happening
in British Columbia Canada if we had one
state that would pass a law with a
carbon price and a hundred percent
dividend to the public then I think
people would wake up and say and they
would say hey this works and it's to the
advantage of the public not to the
polluters
as that Massachusetts had already been
listening and they had begun to take
action a year ago what action
cap-and-trade so getting them to change
direction at this point seems very
difficult I'm going to write something
soon trying to find one state what one
out of 50 states that is in a position
and has leaders that can understand what
is needed and and may be willing to
serve as an example for the other forty
united states
have been trying quite hard California
is a good example but again I think they
have already taken initial steps in in a
different direction so I I haven't
looked carefully enough to say what is
the best candidate State
well I have children and grandchildren
and I have decided that I am going to
try to make clear what the implications
are and I certainly have every right to
do that and I think that scientific
colleagues are now much more willing to
to go along with that if you go back a
few decades scientists tended not to
like it if other scientists spoke up
publicly but I scientific community
recognizes this is an issue where we
have to educate the public
well if we if we allow emissions to
continue at a high rate then this
century we're going to see ice sheets
begin to disintegrate and one of the
things I write about in my book is the
effect that will have on storms because
as Greenland begins to release more
fresh water cold freshwater and
Antarctica does what it does is cool the
North Atlantic Ocean and the Southern
Ocean and that increases the temperature
gradient between low latitudes and
middle and high latitudes and that will
increase the strength of storms that are
driven by horizontal temperature
gradients so our children can look
forward to increasing storms and with a
rising sea level that is going to lead
potentially to a very chaotic situation
because once you have hundreds of cities
in the situation analogous to what
happened in New Orleans
then we've got economic situation which
is just out of control globally on the
long run if that really happened as I
point out at the book over centuries we
could actually get a runaway greenhouse
effect and then that's that's it for all
the species on this planet and as I try
to point out there's no practical way to
escape from this planet
we can't even transfer one species to
another planet I I i discuss the monarch
butterfly and just how complex it is and
for us to hope that we could transplant
life from our planet to another planet
is really unrealistic
fact means once the planet gets warmer
and warmer then the oceans begin to
evaporate and water vapor is a very
strong greenhouse gas even more powerful
than carbon dioxide so you can get to a
situation where it just the oceans will
begin to boil and the planet becomes so
hot that the ocean ends up in the
atmosphere and that happened to Venus
you know that's why Venus no longer has
carbon in its surface
it's its atmosphere is made up basically
of carbon dioxide because it had a
runaway greenhouse effect now the earth
it can go unstable either toward a cold
climate or toward a hot climate and the
earth has had a runaway snowball earth
situation this happened the most
recently about 700 million years ago the
earth froze all the way to the equator
so these runaway situations can occur
we've never had a runaway greenhouse
effect because if we did that would have
been the end once that's a permanent
situation in the case of a snowball
earth when the earth becomes ice-covered
then the planet can escape from that
situation because volcanoes continue to
go off but the weathering process is
greatly reduced
so volcanoes put carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere and it builds up more and
more until there's enough to melt the
ice but we can't push the planet off of
the runaway greenhouse end that's that's
the end for everybody if we do that
first of all you'd have to melt the ice
sheets and that takes a while
Antarctic ice sheet is a couple miles
thick but with continued rapid increase
in greenhouse gases that you could melt
the ice sheets in less than a century
and then things started to get hotter
and hotter so over a period of several
centuries it would be conceivable to
have a runaway greenhouse that would
also require bringing into play what we
call the methane clathrates or methane
hydrates we already observe in the
tundra region in Canada and Siberia that
as the tundra is melting methane frozen
methane begins to be released and
methane is another powerful greenhouse
gas and there have been times in the
Earth's history when the methane
hydrates on the continental shelves
melted and went into the atmosphere and
caused global warming of 6 to 9 degrees
Celsius which you know is 10 to 18
degrees Fahrenheit so that if you add
that on to the carbon dioxide warming
and the the water vapor warming you
could to begin to push the planet into a
very different state
businesses you
Congress does listen to to businesses
and they need to you know our I called
them the captains of industry they're
the ones who are there support is needed
to solve this problem and they need to
put some pressure on Congress to do the
things that are needed rather than
asking for special favors business
leaders would actually like Congress to
set a schedule for changes that are
needed and they would actually favor
most of them I think would favor a
gradually increasing well-established
carbon price rather than this cap and
trade which can be oscillate and you
don't know how that the impacts will be
on your business but if they knew what
the increasing price on carbon was going
to be then they can make the changes to
their business that are needed in order
for them to continue to make money or
even make more money begin to invest in
those things that are carbon free
our businesses that are beginning to
emphasize energy efficiency we we need
in order for that to really work there
does need to be a carbon price and there
are some industries that are beginning
to tell Congress it makes more sense to
have a carbon tax and dividend than it
does to have cap-and-trade
which makes people nervous is the CEO of
ExxonMobil said carbon tax is a good
approach well that makes people nervous
because ExxonMobil has been one of the
biggest producers of carbon dioxide but
in fact that is what's needed so we're
willing to take support from wherever it
comes
I think that businesses do prefer a
approach in which they know what is
going to happen with cap and trade you
don't know what's going to happen